>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C..
>> Dr. John Haskell:
Let me first welcome you
to the Library, to the
Jefferson Building.
I'm John Haskell, Director
of the Kluge Center.
Our offices are right
through the doors over here.
And we're so happy you came.
I want to start by
introducing Yasmina Sioud.
Who's the Deputy Head of
Press and Public Diplomacy
for the Delegation
of the European Union
to the United States.
Yasmina? Right here.
I was like where is she?
[ Applause ]
>> Yasmina Sioud:
Oops, can I move this?
Well, good afternoon, everybody.
I'm delighted to be at
the Kluge Center today
to hear Kluge Fellow
Davide Ceriani.
Good pronunciation.
Presenting his research
on this fascinating topic.
The growth of Italian-American
culture
through opera until the 1940s.
I myself was not a Kluge Fellow.
But I also had the chance as
a master's student in the US
to take advantage of
the Library of Congress.
And its wealth of
documents and materials.
So I, I know how
important this is.
Today's program is a
signature event of the,
of the European Month
of Culture.
Resulting from a collaboration
between the Kluge Center,
the Delegation of the European
Union, the Italian Embassy.
And the Italian Cultural
Institute.
As you may know, or
not, the European Month
of Culture is organized every
year by the European Delegation.
For the month of May and
for the past six years.
And it offers a full month
of cultural events
highlighting the diversity
and the innovation.
Cultures of all our 28
countries that are members
of the European Union.
This year we have close to 100
events in the Washington area.
With participation of
all our 28 embassies
and multiple US cultural and
educational institutions.
So I would like here to extend
the EU delegation's deepest
appreciation to the Kluge Center
for what is now our
third-year collaboration.
In this EU Month of Culture.
So thank you, Dr.
Haskell, for your support.
And for the excellent work
done by Travis Hensley.
I don't know where he is.
But we look forward to many
more years of collaboration.
And I'll leave the floor to Dr.
Haskell for your conversation.
>> Dr. John Haskell: Before
we get to our multimedia show
which will be led by
Dr. Ceriani over here.
Let me, let me just say a word
or two about the Kluge Center.
We bring in scholars in the
humanities and social sciences
by appointment of the Librarian
or by competitive processes.
To take advantage of
the library collections.
And we're really
pleased that this event,
featuring Davide Ceriani,
who is a Kluge Fellow,
is a part of the
European Month of Culture.
First let me recognize
Emanuele Amendola.
Is Emanuel here yet?
>> No.
>> He is not?
Well, he's the [laughter] we
have a longstanding relationship
with the Director of the Italian
Culture Institute as well
as with the Embassy of Italy.
And we're grateful
for that relationship
and its continuation.
Let me turn to Dr. Ceriani.
Who I, who I will
invite up in a second.
But I put my notes
about his career,
it's too long for
me to remember.
[Laughter] He's an Assistant
Professor of Musicology
at the Department of
Music at Rowan University.
That's in Glassboro, New Jersey.
He received his Ph.D. in
Musicology from Harvard in 2011.
Dr. Ceriani earned his degree
in saxophone at the Conservatory
at Bologna, in his
native Italy in 1999.
And is Laurea Cum Laude at the
University of Florence in 2003.
Throughout the 1990s and early
2000s, he performed extensively
as a saxophone player in Italy,
France, and the United States.
Prior to working at Rowan, he
spent two years, 2011 to '13,
as a Mellon Postdoctoral Fellow
in the Department of Music
at Columbia University.
Please help me in welcoming
Dr. Ceriani to the-- .
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
Alright, thank you.
>> Dr. John Haskell:
Let me start
with a very general question
so that we can learn
a little bit more
about the star of
the show tonight.
Where are you from?
Tell us a little bit
about your background.
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani: So
originally from Florence.
And so I lived there
throughout high school.
And then at some point,
even though I was attending
the University of Florence.
But then I started
moving around.
And so through these
European Union programs,
the [foreign language] I lived
in France and Germany a bit.
And then here in
the United States.
And as a part of this constant
journey for both personal
and professional reasons.
I realized that though there
were three words, I would say.
Three concepts that
always stood with me.
And they were like
identity, first.
And that is who you are and
how you define yourself.
Depending on how
[inaudible] whatever you go.
Then a matter of alterity,
that is being the other.
How the others view
you in this new context
where you decide to, to live.
And then acceptance.
That is how you negotiate
with the issue
of identity and alterity.
So your identity
versus who you are
versus what this
new environment is.
And to an extent, I
would say this became
autobiographical research.
Because I realized that
Italians immigrating here.
Although in a totally
different context
but did a very similar thing.
>> Dr. John Haskell: So you,
I guess it goes without saying
that you, that you
developed an interest,
an intense interest in opera.
And you know, United States,
when you're a boy growing
up like my father
used to take me.
Before I can even
remember, to baseball games
at old D.C. Stadium here.
So somehow or another, he was
inculcating this obsession
with baseball that
continues to today.
For no particularly good reason.
How did you get involved
in opera?
Was it, was it something
that your parents
groomed you into that?
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani: No,
not at all, [inaudible].
I have nothing to do or
really do with the music.
My father has a vague interest
in opera, but not really.
No, I wasn't really one of
these kids who start playing
at the age of five, six.
No, it took me quite,
quite a while.
Around 16 I started playing.
In particular, saxophone
[inaudible] earlier,
some beginning.
It wasn't even an
interest in opera.
I listened to opera,
but not really
as a professional interest.
And then by going to the
conservatory, by playing,
I started meeting singers,
attending opera performances,
and that's how it all started.
Even though I have to
say by going abroad
and having people
asking me about opera,
the operatic repertory
especially.
The Italian composers, and
again, made me even more aware
of how the others
viewed me as an Italian.
As sort of interested in
opera perhaps by default.
And so that kind of
vague interest I had
in the beginning developed
in something, yeah, more.
>> Dr. John Haskell:
You obviously grew a good
crowd with the topic.
So maybe this is an
obvious question.
But I'd like to hear
your answers to,
to why what you're working
on here at the Library.
And why the topic of
this, this session.
Why do you think
that's important to us?
What, why does that matter?
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani: Well
I mean, it's important mainly
to better discuss
crucial period in history
of migration to this country.
Of course the, the
history of Italy.
But also because I realized that
in the secondary literature.
That there was a lot on the
socioeconomic accomplishments
of the Italians here in the US.
But not really as much
about opera itself.
In other words, so when,
when Italians came here.
They pretty much worked through.
So for example, they,
they brought
with them their own language.
Which is of course
an important factor
in defining your own identity.
But it can also be
an isolating factor.
And indeed, some of them
kind of isolated themselves
in these Little Italies,
and didn't even need
to, to get out of them.
Food, of course, it's
another important topic.
And you're going to start
a few books that I read,
I started for this research.
Simona Frasca, for example has
written some wonderful essays
on the importance of food.
Simona Frasca wrote this
book on The Diaspora
of Neapolitan Musicians
in New York.
Although she, as many
other major scholars
of Italian music in the US.
They primarily focused on the
Neapolitan repertory in the US.
This popular repertory
which was hugely successful.
She one chapter on Caruso.
But Caruso primarily performing
these Neapolitan songs.
So I realized that there
was a spot missing there.
It was exactly what opera
meant for the Italians.
Particularly in the Northeast.
I would say Boston through
Washington, which was the area
where Italians primarily lived.
So that's how I realized
it was very important.
And Library of Congress had
huge amount of materials to, to,
to work on this topic.
>> Dr. John Haskell: So are
there other specific ways that,
that, that opera was
relevant to immigrants?
And, and, and before
that, you, you,
I guess generally the
mass migration is what?
Eighteen-eighty or so?
In, into the, getting
into the early
to middle decades
of the 20th century.
What in particular.
Did opera mean anything
in the United States
before Italians came?
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
I would say it did,
but it, in a different way.
So before the, the, the 1880s,
1870s, Americans had this sort
of dreamy romantic view of
Italy, thanks to some diaries
of Americans who
traveled through Italy.
And so they, they wrote them.
And lot of people
here read about it.
So [inaudible] came up with
these great quote [inaudible].
After the 19th century,
classical buildings of Greece
and Rome exerted a strong
fascination on American artists,
courthouses, state
legislatures, railroad stations.
And the dwellings of
the wealthy were erected
with the imposing-pillared
facades.
And pediments that characterized
Greek and Roman temples.
And for example there were even
not only American architects
were influenced by the
architecture of Italy.
But some Italian
artists came here.
[Inaudible], for example,
came here with the idea
of building a big
statue of Washington.
He came up with this
[inaudible] he failed
to secure all the
necessary funds.
Brumidi was the author of
the fresco of the "Apotheosis
of Washington, Here in
the US capital next door.
And the first performance
of an opera in its entirety,
in its original language
was [inaudible].
It was Rossini, The
Barber of Seville,
[inaudible] Le Barbier de
Séville, more or less, okay?
We get what, what it is.
And following that performance,
many other major cultural
figures in New York,
including of course the
[inaudible] the author
of the librettos for three
of most important Mozart
operas promoted this art form.
And eventually these
[inaudible] became more
and more popular type
of entertainment.
This book, Opera on the Road.
>> Dr. John Haskell: This is,
this is well before
the, the mass migration?
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
Yes, absolutely.
And the importance
of these two books
of casting opera before
the mass migration is that.
So Katherine Preston
basically argues that
and quite convincingly
that the American elite,
especially New York, tried
to make opera an elitist sort
of type of entertainment.
But they failed because they
essentially they did not have
enough wealth.
Enough money to run the
operas by themselves.
And because here the
state support that existed
in Europe did not exist.
Then they had to draw
in a lot of the people,
the poorer people, making
the prices affordable.
And [inaudible] argues
that there was democracy
of the opera.
Because even though you would
see the different classes
at the opera.
But you also needed
this, everyone in there.
And that's part of
my key argument
that this before
the mass migration,
attending opera was
primarily about class.
When it comes to after or during
the mass migration period.
It becomes matter of
race or better ethnicity.
That is a lot of
these ethnic groups,
including the Italians
as I'll show later.
They showed up to
support their folks.
And that's part of this
major change they had.
So this is pretty much what
happened in the 19th century.
This Music Academy was
established in 1884.
Throughout 1850s, '60s,
throughout the '80s,
Italian opera was really the
dominant type of repertory.
Until we get to the 1880s.
And when, to make
the story short,
the Academy of Music
was challenged
by what nowadays we
call the Met Opera.
By the way, Met Opera not
the one we see nowadays.
But the one that's
on Broadway and 39th
and 40th, old buildings.
And even though at
the beginning,
both opera houses
performed Italian opera.
At some point, right
at the beginning,
those who run the Met Opera say,
"Why don't we try to
change the focus?"
And they started primarily
performing German Opera,
focusing on Wagner.
But why? Because they knew
that especially in New York
at the time, there were
about 250,000 people
of German heritage who
would be totally willing
to support this repertory.
And this is how the
seven-year period
of the Germanized
opera house started.
>> Dr. John Haskell: So on the,
on the, when people were going
to Italian opera in
the middles decades
of the 19th century, were they?
When you got a program,
do you know if it--
was it, were there translations?
Or more just about
the pageantry?
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
No, I mean the,
so there were various
levels of commitments.
But I would say that they knew
of the, the basic of the story.
Most of the people
who attended it.
There were certainly some
translations of an even quality.
But I'm sure people
made the effort.
And a lot of, yeah,
depending on what,
what class you belonged to.
[Inaudible] the wealthiest even
the owners would say the opera
house would have a better
understanding and appreciation.
But one aspect that really
I, particularly impressed
by that concerning the interest
that people had in opera.
In the, in the Northern
California area,
during the gold rush.
During the period,
when 90 to 95%
of people were men living there.
Opera was hugely popular.
And that's [inaudible] how
much people wanted opera.
How many singers traveled there.
And so that was the
situation in an area
that still had to be urbanized.
Can you imagine that kind
of interest that existed
in New York and Philadelphia
and Washington?
>> Dr. John Haskell: So
slight switch of gears.
So now we're getting into the
period of the mass migration.
So we have a lot of
Italians, Italian-Americans.
Do you have examples?
When you know, you've been
researching here at the library
on how the press here
and the music critics.
As, as well as the,
you know, frankly,
the Italian music
critics reacted
in those days during
the mass migration.
To singers and opera
more generally?
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
Yeah, I would say, yes.
I do, and we'll, I'll show
some pictures in a moment.
But before we do that, I wanted
to show these list of critics.
The first three, Fink,
Henderson, [inaudible].
So these were the five most
important music critics
in the United States.
Well, primarily operas
we are talking about.
East Coast, New York
and some Philly area.
In the late 19th and
early 20th century.
Why is this list important?
Because the first three,
Fink, Henderson, [inaudible].
As you can tell, they
were pretty much born
around the same time.
They started their
professional life
as critics around the same time.
Exactly at a time where there
were these quote/unquote
"the Germanized opera house."
Also they were either of German
origins or they spent time
in Germany studying composition.
And of course studying German.
So to them, opera, the classical
opera, was really German opera.
Was the Wagner repertory.
And this is why the Italian
opera, after enjoying
so much popularity during the,
before [inaudible] the
Italian mass migration.
Had such a hard time to
be positively advertised
in the American press.
Aldrich was a bit more balanced,
and Smith was actually,
probably the one who was most
in favor of the Italians.
He was actually the only
one that the conductor,
Arturo Toscanini, trusted.
So it was like he wouldn't
really talk to the others.
But he made an effort
to talk to them.
Anyway, this said, let's
go through some examples
on how the American press and
the Italian-language press
in particular in this case.
Is based in New York.
Reacted to the exact same work.
So here we The Sun, so Henderson
writing this [inaudible]
in 1913 is the one
[inaudible] and [inaudible]
who was the general
manager of the Met Opera,
decides to stage [inaudible].
Now, as you can read there,
like Mr. Caruso at his best.
Presented with a strong cast,
[inaudible] and costumes.
Now one has to read
between the lines.
In other words, when a
critic was not particularly
appreciative of a, of an opera,
at least the headlines
said something positive
about the performers.
About the scenery,
about the costume.
That is to say, [inaudible].
But still, as, you know,
the [inaudible] a
good job doing that.
If you begin and start reading
at some specific passages,
let's see what happens.
[Inaudible] many
absurdities of the libretto.
Or it is the kind of
music to which is beloved
of people devoted to the
elementary things in art.
It's talking about Italians.
I can show you, I have
proof of that later.
And much of the [inaudible]
style of Verdi-- .
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, that's American side.
Let's see what happens in
the Italian-language press.
[Inaudible] trust me, this is
about the exact same
performance, same day.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Last Saturday, we had
the [foreign language]
which has drawn away an
immense public of 4000 people
who gather in religious silence.
In the vast hall of
the Metropolitan.
And basically through
the same divine emotions
of this unanimous enthusiasm to
which it was [inaudible] public
in such a different
context, 54 years ago.
Which was the first performance
of [foreign language].
Only the genius, Verdi,
destined to immortality,
can make this miracle possible.
Is it the same performance?
Yes, it is.
And this is, so this
keeps happening
over and over and over.
This is one year later
in [foreign language].
I don't know if I
need to translate it,
but it's pretty much, it.
This is not the same
performance.
But even before [inaudible] so
[foreign language] 1914, 1915.
[ Inaudible ]
Another example and
then we move on.
So [inaudible] Giordano,
composer of later composer
of late 19th, early 20th
century from the [inaudible].
In 1915, comes up
with this opera,
[foreign language] setting the,
around the Napoleonic Period.
Here we see a similar
kind of rhetoric.
Splendid cast.
The great scene effect, But
music in the military style.
Kind of simple type
of repertory.
Giordano's score not
above previous level.
Which is kind of a way to say,
"Well, he did what he could.
But not really a very
successful opera."
Giordano's score not
inspiring melody.
And I picked these
especially because later,
we're going to see
something about the melody
in the Italian-language press.
Now, Italian-language
press, [foreign language].
The immense success of
Umberto Giordano's work.
A great triumph of Italian art,
thanks to [inaudible] the
Italian general manager
of the Met.
This sort of rhetoric,
Italian composer,
triumph of Italian art ,or
something that constantly happen
over and over and over.
This one is the part
that I prefer.
After each performance,
the Italian press would,
in this case [foreign language]
would cherry-pick passages
from the American press.
Taken totally out of context.
And [inaudible] a positive.
They'll say everything
was bad except for this.
And so this is, and this
was, these were articles
for the members of
the Italian community
that they wanted believed,
the newspapers wanted
them to believe.
That everything had gone great
at the, at the performance.
So people either could
not read English.
Or did not both enough.
>> Dr. John Haskell: Yeah,
you've got to be careful
because there's people in this
room who, who depend on that
for blurbs on their books.
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
That's great!
Again, it's [inaudible]
100 years ago.
So it's all good.
Now I'm sure that everything
is totally different.
Actually, one thing
that we notice is
that this is small parenthesis
about an important one.
Is that opera has an importance
back then only comparable
to what Hollywood is today.
Like the amount of space
literally that you find
in both the American newspapers,
Italian-language newspaper.
Even like German-language
newspaper were easily comparable
to that section about Hollywood
actors and the Hollywood movies.
With the main difference
that now we have primarily
American actors acting
in Hollywood movies.
Back then we were
primarily having European,
not only of course,
but primarily European singers
coming here to have success.
And that indeed created
the sort of tension
that [inaudible] especially
in connection with Caruso.
Anyway, just a few notes just
to show you how this
rhetoric changed
in the Italian-language
newspapers.
So we have this American press
had words of great enthusiasm
for the opera of
Maestro Giordano.
And they recognized, the
American journalists,
that Madame Sans-Gene
contains wonderful [inaudible].
But for the modernity of the
technique, musical techniques.
And the freshness and
originality of melody
which is exactly the
part that we saw earlier
that wasn't terribly
successful one.
Now what happened when the
German repertory was performing?
In general, the reviews
in the Italian newspaper were
not particularly positive.
Unless these were in
the hands or conducted
by an Italian conductors.
And this is the case of
Toscanini who [foreign language]
as the last part
of the [inaudible].
The last part of the
[inaudible] of Wagner.
And of course Toscanini
triumphs with the [inaudible]
that he's noted to
triumph thanks
to the Italian conductors.
So there is a victory thanks
to the ingenious Italian
of the Metropolitan Opera.
And of course the
American press is totally,
like agrees in admiring
Toscanini,
not necessarily Wagner.
Same story.
[ Inaudible ]
Before Toscanini, not as much.
[Laughter] Finally,
what happened
with American composers?
This is very interesting
because in general,
it's true that American opera
has not been as successful.
Not here in the US.
And not here in the US as much
as the Italian, the French,
or the German repertory.
But there was in general a
movement of American critics
who wanted more American opera.
Or at least foreign opera
performed in English.
But also they wanted some
American composers being staged
at the Met.
So these, [inaudible] as part
of this rhetoric was someone
that says, "We don't want
opera in French or in German.
We want it in the vernacular
that is in, in English."
At one point, [inaudible] some
sort gives into this pressure
and agrees to, to stage an
opera by Horatio Parker.
And American composer
who was teaching at Yale.
So one of the most prestigious.
And agrees to stage
this opera, Mona.
M-o-n-a. At the Met with
an expense of about $40,000
which translates nowadays
to about one million
dollars, a major performance.
See how the Italian
press reacts to that.
[Foreign language]
writes of Parker,
Mona is $40,000 thrown at sea.
[Laughter] Just to see how
welcome the American press was
toward these new, these
American repertory.
I also thought as I pointed
to briefly discuss something.
Because this year is
the 100th anniversary
of the first performance
of Puccini [inaudible].
A series of three short operas
that were premiered here
in 1919, here in the
US at Met in 1918.
And pretty much we follow
a similar kind of rhetoric.
A great artistic events of
the Metropolitan Opera House.
Three new operas.
The American press was a bit
more skeptical in the sense
that they remember the Puccini
of Tosca, Madame Butterfly,
so like the, the
great successes here,
the late 19th, early
20th century.
But they were not terrible
happy with these new operas
because it was missing
these belle canto,
the beautiful singing
type of style.
And indeed only the last one
of the [foreign language]
which is the, the comic opera
with the [inaudible]
the famous aria.
Was the one that was
appreciated overall.
Otherwise, it's powerful
in conception,
but melody quality is not
ingratiating except again,
for this last, last one.
So that's, and then, I
would say a few words
about Caruso is probably worthy.
In the sense that we think of
Caruso as this hero figure.
So the one that was able
to bring together the Italian
communities and the Americans.
And everybody was
happy with him.
And he was a great figure
that everybody agreed upon.
Not as much or better.
Some of the aspects that I will
mention here are relatively
well known.
But they certainly
deserve a closer look
to show a different side
of Caruso or better.
The difference in Caruso
and how he was perceived
by the American press.
So here I'm showing
the, the again,
what we know about Caruso.
Grandiose event of
Italian [inaudible].
Caruso stands there
in the middle
between Toscanini
and [inaudible].
This was the first,
the first performance
of [inaudible] at the Met.
Just a few quotes from
[foreign language].
[ Inaudible ]
And then these another title
that proves how Italians knew
of Caruso even before
he came to, to New York.
[Inaudible] was actually
the impresario,
the one who ran the Met who
brought Caruso to the Met.
Here is Caruso in Little Italy.
He has people around who took
care of, took care of him.
How do we know this
is Little Italy?
Well, that [inaudible]
there at the top is clearly
like southern Neapolitan accent
which has these [inaudible]
it's called the [inaudible].
In the English, a-p,
a-p-o-c-o-p-e and is pretty much
like dropping through a
process of [inaudible].
The last vowel of the word.
It's like a typical
element of the dialect
of the Neapolitan in particular.
And we know that
Neapolitans who are
like prominent in
the Little Italy.
So all these drawings,
they're kind of nice, you know,
with Caruso eating
the spaghetti.
And so I know, I know.
[ Inaudible ]
And we also know that
he liked the spaghetti,
the lamb, the [inaudible].
It's all good, the
kind of drawings
which I find quite you
know, nice and funny.
And just-- what they find
much more disturbing.
And here I need to open a
little, well, it's [inaudible].
It's a fact.
It was the Monkey House scandal.
What was the Monkey
House scandal?
Caruso came here to
this country in 1903.
Had great success
at the beginning.
Then I think, '06,
he was convicted,
essentially for molestation.
For you know [inaudible]
touching a woman at this,
the Bronx Zoo in New York.
He professed his innocence.
This woman said no.
He actually did that to me.
In the end of this
very disturbing story,
he was convicted but with a
fine that was basically a joke
of $10, the equivalent
of $250 nowadays.
Someone who earned five
million dollars a season,
it was pretty much nothing.
So it pretty much the
worst possible decision.
Because on the one hand,
he was convicted as guilty
for something that he always
said, "I didn't do it."
And this woman pretty
much say this guy kind
of walking away if
that was true.
It was like basically doing
a great injustice to her.
Stanley Jackson wrote
this biography.
He's not a musicologist.
He's a lawyer, and
this book is from 1972.
And this is the first part,
how he describes the Italian.
"Caruso did not pinch the
woman or even touching her.
He assets that she smile at him,
and he had to smile
back politely.
Surprisingly, she was not called
as a witness and basically
because this woman
said, "Well, I,
Caruso's friends are dangerous."
Now before I show
you next, next image.
Another quote from the book.
Keep in mind that
this is a book if not
like totally scholarly book.
But a book written by
this lawyer, and published
by a very well-respected
New York publisher.
So something that [inaudible]
has supposedly a peer
review process.
Here is what this
person says, 1972.
"Fondling or tweaking a
ladies' behind was and remains
so prevalent [inaudible]
in Italy and Latin America.
That he, Caruso, might
well have instinctively
and without considering it
more than a playful kiss."
Now, why do I show this,
this obscenity over here?
If this was the kind of
rhetoric, this thing happened
in 1972 in a, less call
it a scholarly book.
Can you imagine what kind of
rhetoric what was going on in,
you know, people just
talking to each other in 1906?
It was the kind of rhetoric
that brought to this.
Caruso's offered a bodyguard
by Sicilian relatives.
[Inaudible] between the two
Sicilians with the radio,
with the knives to stab, I
guess, anyone who's you know,
could potentially
threaten his reputation.
By the way, dates say 1907.
I'm sorry, like it's 1906 of
course right after the event.
So in a sense, again, after
this event which everyone later,
the press, they tell
American community
that they all try to
swipe like behind.
>> Dr. John Haskell:
Under the rug.
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
Under the rug, thank you.
That's the expression.
And they came to the
worst possible outcomes
for the reasons I said before.
And because of course
this wrote these series
of drawings, I just picked one.
But there are many others.
Against the Italian
community of, of New York.
And these again, an event
that was very disturbing.
That is certainly not discussed
as much as it was back then.
But it certainly it's something
that brought a [inaudible] not
only on Caruso's reputation.
Again, it should
have had some negat--
very negative consequences
on him since it happened.
But more in general, the
Italian community had much
to do with that.
Caruso also, [inaudible]
singer that as I said earlier,
a lot of these singers
who were as popular
as actors in these days.
So a lot of the American
newspapers thought
of the singers, and
Caruso more than others.
Because he was the one who made
more money than anyone else.
Depicting him as the one who
was only interested in dollars.
So they are newspapers
showed much
of the earnings of these people.
Caruso, so $200,000
as I said earlier.
Translates roughly into the five
million per season nowadays.
And finally, well,
is this funny?
I don't think that much.
But let me give you a context.
At some point, Caruso was asked
by the Italian-American mafia
to pay a certain
amount of money.
He initially agreed
for a lower amount.
When they asked for more, he
reported that to the police.
And so these people were
brought to, to, to, to court
and eventually jailed.
That the black hand
was actually,
many people confuse here,
they suppose the black hand
with the Italian-American mafia.
But in reality, the
black hand was
like how the mafia sent these
letters with these like hands.
And very often with a knife
as well to threaten the people
in order to make them pay.
And so all of these American
newspapers wants Caruso
denounced this fact
that he was protected
by the police everywhere.
And so they, they tried to be
[inaudible] with the police-- .
[ Inaudible ]
This is another example.
Caruso caged during
the performance.
And again the, the
police with the guns.
So is this funny?
Well, I mean, you look at
things like that, it is funny.
But it is funny if it
doesn't touch you personally.
Many people in the, the,
the Italian-American community
were unfortunately touched
by this phenomenon.
It's this kind of
funny in a sense
but also disturbing
on the other.
In the end, when we talk about
Caruso, I think we are talking
about a performer that
for the Americans and all,
it wasn't really a threatening
figure among this community
of Italians that
moved here to the US.
But he was not, as well
as were not the Italians
who performed on stage.
When someone like
[inaudible] was asked
to actually run an opera house,
well, we'll see what happened.
And I'd like to close this
part with this funny video
of Caruso trying to ingratiate
himself to the American audience
by making these faces.
It kind of gives us
a sense of yeah, how,
of these very expressive faces
that he did, he made
on, on stage.
>> Dr. John Haskell: So you
know, the Kluge Center, as,
as many people in the room know.
But perhaps not everybody that
we will have at any given time.
You know, we could have as many
as 30 scholars in residence,
about what we have right now.
And, and there's a, you know,
of course a lot of interaction.
That's part of the point.
And what we hear from this
gentleman is, is a conversation
about hey, I'm finding
these autobiographies
of Italian immigrants.
And that's you know an
important part of his research.
And I was hoping
that you could speak
to how these autobiographies
are, are informing your research
into the perception of Italian
opera by Italian-Americans.
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani: Yeah!
Absolutely!
I would say this was one of the
three most important outcomes
of this research
in my time here.
What I'm going to do is
going to show a few quotes.
And then explain
why these quotes
in particular are so important.
Pascal D'Angelo's, one
who became a very well
respected author, writer,
and poet here in the US.
Describes in this
autobiography of him
as an immigrant to the US.
Eventually becoming again
a successful writer.
How he discovered opera.
And this story, it's very
common among the Italians.
So he says that during
the summer of 1919.
I began to hear much about
the Aida, so Verdi's Aida
but did not know
exactly what it was.
So [inaudible] friend of him
[inaudible] had been to see it.
But he was unable to tell
me much about it except
that it was a fine
parade in it which is
of course the [inaudible],
Act Two.
So about the same time
happened to glance
over at Italian newspapers.
You know, how he can
learn about the opera.
And saw an advertisement that
his opera was represented
in open-air at the Sheep
Shed Bay Racetrack.
I decided to go and hear it.
And I went by asking my way--
basically the entry
because he's from Brooklyn.
And then I heard these
supreme melodies around me.
I felt the impulse to
rush home to our boxcar
and compose another Aida.
Even though I didn't
know much about music.
And [inaudible] music,
it's kind of difficult
to write something like Aida.
In this autobiography
keeps trying, he fails.
And that's how he
decides to become a poet.
Of course [inaudible] but of
course he had to change career.
[Inaudible] was a very well
respected Italian-American.
Scholars describe something
from his own personal life.
That he's this [inaudible]
the Verdi.
[ Inaudible ]
By the way, in the other
room, we have artifacts.
We have books, scores,
and the phonograph
if you wish to take
a look later.
He must have had an
extraordinary ear for music
because the [inaudible]
of the children
and [inaudible] usually
coincided
with the climaxes of Aida.
[ Inaudible ]
He favored the most.
All of them of course,
Verdi's opera.
Last example, [inaudible]
describing her grandfather.
When the [inaudible] Americano,
I reported a particular success
of the Metropolitan Opera House.
He, her grandfather,
would buy a recording
of his favorite arias sung
by his favorite artists.
[ Foreign Language ]
And then she described how
she learned about opera.
Now, why are these
passages so important?
And why do I pick them?
Well, one talks about
Italians going to the opera
that is attending
the opera live.
And as I'll show later,
sticking altogether in order
to support their performers.
The other one in the middle is
about the private
enjoyment of opera.
Having a phonograph
and basically having the
operas perform there as a sort
of collective, a sonic
experience as a collective rite.
Even during you know
the normal situation
with children running and so on.
And the other is about Italians
reading the Italian-American
newspapers and learning
through them
about these operatic
performances.
So we all knew that
that happened.
But what these experiences at
Kluge allowed me was the time
to find plenty of evidence.
I limited it to three.
But we found those.
And my friend Katherine
[inaudible] because it's
when we were on the, we
were on the opposite side.
So we were on the
[inaudible] of our cubicles.
And every time I would find
one, I was like, "Ha-ha!"
And she knew that I had
found a new, a new one.
[Laughter] I was [inaudible]
there when these happened.
Now, and another very compelling
evidence that I found was images
of Italians going to the opera.
And here we go.
So well the one there
you're seeing is clearly
[inaudible] Caruso.
This from the Chicago
Daily News from 1910.
And up there we have
these very moved Italians.
So I know how they are Italians
and the mom might even cry.
Of course the seats
were very cheap,
but very much into
the performance.
And we see at the bottom
like the most expensive seat.
The other seats that
we know were the areas
where the wealthiest
Americans, sometimes.
Those who literally
own the opera house.
They don't care that much.
Oh, this guy is performing,
whatever he's doing.
[Laughter] We don't know.
It's, you know, it's kind of
funny to see these contrasts.
Now another evidence, 1908.
This is the Manhattan
Opera House.
This is a performance
of [foreign language].
And here is the close-up with
the gallery most of Italian.
And the de-- again
like the title,
as I show earlier is with,
with Italy on the Italians
that gathered up
there, presumably right
after performance of aria
of [foreign language].
Like very overexcited.
Very happy that she did
a great performance.
And this is supposedly your
average Italian reacting
to an Italian performer.
Apparently like [inaudible]
prima Dona [inaudible]
for New York Herald.
[ Inaudible ]
Describes these very happy
Italian at the performance.
This one it's supposedly
the Metropolitan Opera House
in the, the.
So this, this is something
that has already been
published in, in a book.
And according to the
caption of this book.
This is a -- .
[ Inaudible ]
Now I had a chance once to
talk to Toscanini's grandson
who could have told
me more about it.
Unfortunately, I didn't have
the chance to talk a little.
And unfortunately, he died
a couple of years ago.
But we trust this book that
this is exactly what happened.
Okay, more images
about Italians.
If you don't mind, maybe I
should briefly read these.
And then we move
onto something else.
So this is how the Musical
America described Italians
staying at the opera in 1909.
They came out from the Little
Italy on the East Side,
where the Met Opera is.
They come out from the
[inaudible] spaghetti
on the West Side.
And they crowded into the
Met Opera Monday night
until they stood four and
five deep in the [inaudible]
at the gallery, up there.
They had come to welcome their
great compatriot, Caruso,
and they were prepared to
stop the action of the opera.
When he appeared on the stage
and shout [inaudible]
et cetera, et cetera.
So the point of this
article makes essentially.
The Italians only know
one kind of music.
And they show up for their
own, their own operas.
In a sense this sort of makes
it even more compelling.
The argument I made earlier
that we were moving from class
or race or ethnicity because
this kind of rhetoric.
Even though it was not so
clearly phrased, but it had been
for the German as well.
For the Czechs as well.
For all those immigrants
who by night feel
that the opera part is the least
expensive part of the Met Opera.
And again, all the evidence
of this wonderful example is
of the Boston Opera House.
It's something that
further proves this point.
Finally, I'd like to discuss a
bit, so we'll listen some music
on how opera was popularized.
Opera was popularized of course
through this aria recorded.
And then being like you
know sold as a phonograph.
But also a key element that we
often forget nowadays was the
band culture when, that
was so popular in the US.
It was of course in Italy.
So the Italians recreated
these bands here in the US.
Let's see, here we have the
cities and associations.
This one was in Oswego,
New York.
Pueblo, Colorado.
This was the [inaudible]
band in Boston.
And all these band
conductors, in order to,
to have success basically.
To sell their recordings.
They started transcribing
passages from operas.
Duet, arias and so on.
I have a selected a couple
to just show you how
incredibly identical they were.
So they literally
transcribed a duet.
The aria for these bands.
So Italians could enjoy either
the original or the band copy.
This one is from-- .
[ Foreign Language ]
I'll be happy to say more
something about the plot,
but just pay attention
to the melody.
[ Music ]
And here is the transcription
of [foreign language],
one of the most famous
band conductors.
The duet between trombone
and the baritone [inaudible].
[ Music ]
Literally identical.
Here is another one.
I put the subtitles here.
So just [inaudible].
Thank you, Andrew, for helping
me with these, these videos.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Inaudible ]
[ Music ]
Okay, and here is [foreign
language] performing the same
exact passage and she
of course just-- .
[ Inaudible ]
[ Music ]
Yeah, and this is really
a type of repertory
that maybe has not
really investigated
as much as we should.
And yeah, definitely a good
step ahead in the future.
>> Dr. John Haskell: Well,
Davide, thank you very much.
This was extraordinarily
interesting.
>> Dr. Davide Ceriani:
Thank you.
>> Dr. John Haskell: We
appreciate your efforts.
And finishing with the
beautiful music is perfect.
Please join me in thanking him.
[ Applause ]
We have a reception back here.
Wine, beer, et cetera.
And, and some, some
other appetizers.
You're not allowed to bring
them back into the collections.
But please do check out the
collections in the back.
I want to alert you
to two things.
Before I set your free and
the seatbelt sign comes off.
And that is that we have
an event next Tues--
an event next Thursday at 2:00
on The Bible in American life
with Mark Knoll and
Lincoln Mullin
who are historians of the Bible.
I think you'll find
it interesting.
It's 2:00 right here
in this room.
And then just to put on
your calendar going forward.
We have July 19, the Restoring
the American Dream which is part
of our Daniel Inouye
Institute Lecture Series.
Anne Compton will be moderating
a conversation with two authors
and columnists, Ross
Douthat of the New York Times
and E.J. Dionne of
the Washington Post.
And the first event next
week is at 3:00, not 2:00.
The Inouye lecture's at 6:30,
so that's an evening event.
But again, thank you
for your attendance.
And you'll have an
opportunity, to,
to chat with Dr.
Ceriani at the reception.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.